hallo deutschland ganz herzlich
willkommen bei uns schön dass sie
eingeschaltet haben
radfahrer und jogger tragen keine
gesichtsmasken stoßen aber unzählige
micro tröpfchen durch den mund aus
besteht hier ein erhöhtes
ansteckungsrisiko
das ist eine ihrer fragen an unseren
corona experten in wenigen minuten gibt
es die antwort darauf erst einmal das
wichtigste zu corona im überblick diese
strand idylle trügt denn auf borkum
werden die wegen des corona virus
ausbleibenden touristen immer mehr zum
problem
schließlich gilt ohne gäste keine
umsätze ohne umsätze keine jobs da wir
ja alle vom tourismus leben ist das für
uns schon ziemlich existenzbedrohend was
auf uns zukommt aber der blick in die
zukunft
er macht einfach ein bisschen angst
borkum steht faktisch unter quarantäne
nur einheimische dürfen die insel noch
betreten
entsprechend eingeschränkt ist der
fährverkehr wo viele jobs auf dem spiel
stehen
schlechte nachrichten auch aus münchen
das oktoberfest es wegen des corona
virus abgesagt letztes jahr sei es hier
noch so aus an die einhaltung von
abstandsregeln wäre aktuell kaum zu
denken
auch medizinisch hat das virus
deutschland weiter fest im griff
nach erhebungen der johns hopkins
universität sind heute stand 16 30
147.000 103 infektionen durch test
bestätigt 95 1200 menschen gelten als
genießen es ist gelungen in den letzten
wochen einen deutlich geringeren
täglichen anstieg der fallzahlen gegen
der letzten woche gegenüber der vorwoche
zu erreichen
für die letzten tage gilt aber weiter
vorsicht denn es kann hier noch zu
nachmeldungen kommen die das bild wieder
etwas verändern
auch dänemark will zurück zur normalen
leben und so dürfen sich diese eisbären
im kopenhagener zoo bald wieder über
besucher freuen
für die wahl der zu einen monat lang
geschlossen jetzt geht der betrieb
weiter mit neuen regeln
wir werden zwei reihen an der kasse
haben und kontrollen
einem flughafen so werden wir die
abstandsregeln einhalten
außerdem wird die besucherzahl begrenzt
die eisbären finden das womöglich gar
nicht mal so schlecht
eine der aktuellsten fragen im
zusammenhang mit corona beantwortet uns
jetzt professor doktor schmidt-chanasit
virologe am bernhard-nocht-institut für
tropenmedizin in hamburg immer mehr
bundesländer und städte haben bereits
eine masken pflicht eingeführt oder
überlegen eine einzuführen zumindest in
bussen bahnen und geschäften für wie
sinnvoll und wirksam halten sie denn
diese maßnahme als virologe ja also hier
gibt es eine ganz klare empfehlung des
robert-koch-instituts überall dort wo
der mindestabstand nicht eingehalten
werden kann kann ein korrekt verwendeter
mund nasenschutz oder alltags maske dazu
führen das risiko der übertragung eben
zu mindern und genau das wird jetzt eben
umgesetzt im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr wenn es dort eben zu
menschenansammlung kommt oder auch in
sehr beengten läden macht es sinn diesen
mund nasenschutz oder eben die alltags
maske richtig korrekt zu verwenden
gleich antworten sie auch noch auf die
fragen unserer zuschauer in bezug auf
masken wir sprechen uns gleich wieder
vielen dank für den moment ja die lage
ist gerade angespannt auch
wirtschaftlich viele menschen und firmen
sind jetzt gezwungen umzudenken und
kreativ zu werden und einigen gelingt es
dadurch sogar von der krise profitieren
sowie ein unternehmen aus wuppertal es
vertreibt acrylglas wie es jetzt an
supermarktkassen in arztpraxen beim
bäcker oder in vielen büros gebraucht
wird an sich ein gutes geschäft aber es
gibt dabei ein großes problem im
nordrhein-westfälischen wuppertal werden
bei der firma grünke diese aufsteller
als spuk schutz geformt in corona zeiten
heiß begehrt doch vor wenigen tagen
bekommt der familienbetrieb post eine
firma verbietet alexander grünke jetzt
seinen spuck spuk schutz zu nennen und
fordert 16.250 euro
ich bin aus allen wolken gefallen und
markenrecht schallt ist immer sehr teuer
und ja da konnte ich erst mal nicht
schlafen
das hat mich doch ich mitgenommen seit
jahren produziert grünke die aussteller
aus acryl sie schützen lebensmittel oder
in geschäften das gegenüber im internet
bezeichnet die firma ihre aufsteller mit
dem gebräuchlichen begriff spuck schutz
dafür wird sie jetzt plötzlich abgemahnt
der grund eine firma aus österreich hat
sich den begriff spuck schutz bei der eu
als marke eintragen lassen unglaublich
wer das wort gewerblich verwendet
braucht plötzlich eine genehmigung wir
sehen das nicht als marke sondern als
beschreibender begriff also für das ding
selbst so wie ich gesagt habe wie wie
kaffeemaschine da gibt es verschiedene
hersteller
die nennen das aber alle kaffeemaschinen
das wäre genauso als würde ich mir die
kaffeemaschinen schützen lassen und alle
die eine kaffeemaschine vertreibe
verklagen
das kann doch nicht sein aber warum
schützt eine eu-behörde das wort spuck
schutz
das zuständige amt für geistiges
eigentum mit sitz im spanischen alicante
erklärt nur lapidar wir kommentieren
niemals einzelfälle
die abmahnende firma wiederum sieht sich
völlig im recht der anwalt teilt uns mit
unserer mandantschaft ist zu
abwehrmaßnahmen benötigt um den bestand
der marke zu sichern für grünke geht es
um sein geschäft seine kunden etwa die
ärztin sabine mucha können das alles
nicht glauben ein spuk schutz ist für
mich eine beschreibung dieses
gegenstandes hier und ist für mich kein
marken habe das ist dann doch menschen
gibt die halt aus dieser krise noch
gewinn gewinn im sinne von monetären
gewinn schöpfen wollen das finde ich
ziemlich erschüttern alexander grünke
ist kein einzelfall viele andere firmen
wurden ebenfalls abgemahnt am ende wird
wohl ein gericht entscheiden müssen ob
in deutschland ein spuck spuk schutz
heißen darf unglaublich dass corona
virus treibt viele hotels an den rand
des ruins keine touristen kein einkommen
davon ist auch ein gran hotel in
heidelberg betroffen mit 100 zimmern 14
junius bieten drei appartements zwei
restaurants und einer penthouse suite
ist luxus pur
das fünf-sterne-hotel derzeit 155 jahren
von einer familie geführt jetzt steht es
vor einer riesigen herausforderung
wo bis vor kurzem noch alle plätze
belegt waren bleiben in corona zeiten
die tische leer
margarita per bahre frühstück
mutterseelenallein hier im gran hotel
europäischer hof in heidelberg wir sind
hierhergekommen weil mein mann an der
uniklinik operiert werden musste ihr
mann liegt auf der intensivstation
außer ihr wohnen im hotel gerade mal
noch sechs weitere gäste für die chefin
und die belegschaft heißt dass
notbetrieb
wir haben nicht ganz zugemacht weil wir
immer noch gäste haben die aus
medizinischen gründen hier in heidelberg
sind und die einfach nicht weg reisen
durften also die haben keine flüge
bekommen in ihre heimatländer und für
die haben wir gesagt die werden wir
nicht auf die straße setzen der
europäische hof ist eines von wenigen
deutschen fünf sterne stadthotels in
familienbesitz
geführt wird es in vierter generation
von caroline von kretschmann
nach einem guten start ins jahr kam im
märz der korona schock am 23 märz an
wird das haus dicht gemacht mehr oder
weniger bis auf den notbetrieb und
seitdem kriegen wir endlich nur schon
jung also die kollegen in der
reservierung haben innerhalb von drei
tagen 400.000 euro raus studieren müssen
aus den büchern für das traditionshaus
bedeutet dass dringend kosten senken
kurzarbeit für 80 prozent der 165
mitarbeiter der rest stemmt den
notbetrieb zusammen mit den
auszubildenden die müssen weiter
beschäftigt und ausgebildet werden
jennifer müller kann der krise sogar
etwas positives abgewinnen
man kann sich so ein bisschen das
arbeitsleben nach der ausbildung
vorstellen
man habe viel mehr verantwortung in dem
sinne gerade nimmt sie bestellungen für
den neuen außer haus service entgeht
auch das ungewöhnlich für ein
fünf-sterne-haus krisenzeiten machen
eben erfinderisch
küchenchef julian schon bereitet eine
frühstücks box vor
[Musik]
die leute müssen weiterhin beschäftigen
und auch neue ideen kommen oder kreativ
sein auch wenn mit der krise umgeht
an diese frühstücks box legt die chefin
letzte hand an
denn die wird sie gleich persönlich aus
rund 150 solcher boxen hat das hotel
schon verkauft das beschäftigt die küche
und hilft in verbindung mit den gästen
zu bleiben der umsatz damit aber deckt
gerade mal vier prozent der laufenden
kosten
die größte gefahr geht es in den letzten
paar wochen war die dass wir keine
liquidität mehr haben da sind wir immer
noch dran wir sind noch in verhandlungen
mit unserer hausbank werden leider keine
möglichkeit bisher gehabt an die
fördermittel des bundes unterländer zu
kommen langfristig ist die gefahr das
ist lange dauert bis wir wieder in den
normalbetrieb übergehen können und ich
glaube nicht an drei monate an sechs
monate ich glaube brauchen bis ende
nächsten jahres vielleicht sogar bis
mitte 2022 bis wir wieder auf das
ursprungs niveau vor der krise gekommen
sind
die ungewissheit eine nie da gewesene
situation in 155 jahren hotel geschichte
täglich hält caroline von kretschmann
rücksprache mit ihren eltern über die
lage
es ist natürlich für uns alle schon sehr
schwer für ein familienunternehmen
wir sind einfach angewiesen darauf dass
wir das dass dieser laden immer aufwies
und 365 tage und 24 stunden hotel koch
daniel stehling ist einer von denen die
den laden am laufen halten
mit seinen auszubildenden kocht er heute
das abendessen weniger fliegen und gäste
am anfang war ein bisschen komplizierter
mit den azubis bis man sich da ein
gekauft hat muss man sich da gefunden
hat wer was wo wer was kann wo wir sind
aber jetzt mittlerweile in der dritten
woche ist es echt perfekt
daniel stelligen wechselt sich mit
seinem küchenchef ab und kann so noch
arbeiten viele seiner kollegen sind
dagegen seit wochen zu hause
wo es dann heißt das wir komplett zu
machen da sind halt bei einem und dem
anderen mitarbeiter schon mal so ein
tränchen geflossen weil das gehalt ist
nicht bombastisch in der gastronomie 60
davon das sind dann ungefähr 600 700
euro miete in heidelberg unbezahlbar
deswegen hat die chefin eine klare
forderung an die politik dass man
einfach in der zeit das kurzarbeitergeld
eben auf 80 prozent hoch setzt weil wir
leider nicht in der lage sind
aufzustocken weil es eben so großer
kostenblock ist und in diesem
unternehmen jeder euro drin steckt
zurzeit sitzt caroline von kretschmann
oft bis spät abends am schreibtisch um
die tradition zu bewahren und den
mitarbeitern eine perspektive zu
schaffen
wir drücken die daumen dass die familie
ihr hotel retten kann
wir sind jetzt wieder verbunden mit
professor doktor schmidt-chanasit er ist
virologe am bernhard-nocht-institut für
tropenmedizin in hamburg er beantwortet
ihre fragen zu corona hallo noch mal wir
haben eine frage von christa bekommen
sie fragt es heißt die masken schützen
nicht den träger sondern nur die anderen
wenn alle eine maske tragen müssten doch
aber alle geschützt sein oder irre ich
mich
naja der schutz ist eben nicht
hundertprozentig natürlich werden einige
tröpfchen abgefangen nichtsdestotrotz
sitzt die maske natürlich nicht so fest
an das nun alles aufgehalten wird
insofern besteht natürlich immer noch
ein infektionsrisiko
man muss sich von dem gedanken einfach
lösen das masken das allheilmittel sind
das sind sie sicherlich nicht sie sind
ein wichtiger baustein in bestimmten
situationen und müssen zielgerichtet
korrekt verwendet werden damit sie dann
auch etwas nützen eine frage von
christine kirsch ich habe mir aus reiner
baumwolle eine maske genäht muss ich sie
immer bei 90 grad waschen oder könnte
ich die maske auch mit einem heißen
dampfbügeleisen desinfizieren
nun da gibt es unterschiedliche methoden
im grunde reicht es wenn die masken mit
ein bisschen seife ausgewaschen werden
sämtliche dekadenz hin also seifen
führen zu einer inaktivierung des virus
das kann natürlich denn bei erhöhten
temperaturen also 60 grad oder 40 50
grad
auch noch ergänzt werden aber das ist
vollkommen ausreichend wichtig ist dass
zumindest auch einen tropfen seife dabei
ist joachim wörz fragt um nicht auf
betrügereien hereinzufallen welche art
von schutzmaske soll ich kaufen
na ja wir reden ja hier über die
selbstgemachten schutzmasken bitte
kaufen sie nicht die medizinischen
schutzmasken die werden dringend
benötigt insofern ist hier eine
überprüfung wie in den krankenhäusern
nicht erforderlich weil sie sowieso
nicht den qualitätsstandards entsprechen
also wir reden über die selbstgemachten
masken und eben über die nicht
medizinisch masken eine weitere prüfung
ist dort nicht notwendig weil der schutz
von so eben nicht hundertprozentig sein
kann
damit müssen sie eben noch mal klar
sozusagen werden dass sie andere damit
schützen und das eben auch nur bedingt
und es ist nicht zum selbstschutz
gedacht eine anonyme frage gibt es
studien darüber welche vor erkrankten
risikogruppen besonders von corinna
virus betroffen sind wie verhält es sich
zum beispiel mit übergewicht ja das sind
eine ganze reihe von vorerkrankungen die
dort eine rolle spielen können
erkrankungen herz kreislauf erkrankungen
diabetes atemwegserkrankungen das können
alles risikofaktoren seien welche
erkrankung dort eine größere rolle
spielen das ist bisher nicht bekannt
rauchen gehört übrigens auch dazu bei
übergewicht kann man pauschal nicht
davon ausgehen dass dies ein
risikofaktor ist für schwerwiegende
verläufe ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich
für diesen überblick und unser heutiges
corona kompakt finden sie auch im
internet auf youtube und zwar auf dem
kanal der zdf heute